[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique de fin de semaine au
sommaire la cinquième vague alors que
l'épidémie s'emballe chez nos voisins
européens
la crainte d'une nouvelle vague en
france et dans retour des restrictions
sanitaires se fait sentir après plus
d'un an et demi de crise la lassitude se
manifestent jusqu'aux antilles faut-il
craindre encore plus de défiance
vis-à-vis des restrictions comment le
qu'ovide impact la campagne en cours
c'est le débat de la semaine alexis
poulin et jacques de guillebon vous
éclaire ensuite sur l'actualité
politique de demain dans le monde
d'après mais d'abord la droite et la
gauche traditionnelle
ont-elles disparu
les républicains enchaîne une série de
débats interminables dont il ne ressort
aucun leader une gauche éclatée façon
puzzle laissant planer le spectre d'un
rassemblement qui n'arrivera sans doute
jamais messieurs ouvrons le débat avec
votre sentiment sur le début de campagne
de ces blocs traditionnels un de leurs
candidats at il encore une chance de
figurer au moins au second tour
bonjour jacques bonjour alexis alors un
candidat d'un parti traditionnel au
second tour oui je pense alors ce qu'on
a vu ces dernières semaines sur les
nombreux débats du camp des républicains
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
c'est le même débat à chaque fois avec
un ennui à la peur de pas taper ne pas
dépasser non plus trop d'assurer que
l'unité du camp et là je pense que le
psychodrame fillon qui est dans toutes
les têtes il faudrait surtout pas se
faire d'ennemis avant d'être élu
champion de la droite
donc on a l'impression d'un débat assez
mou mais je dirais quand même c'est un
débat qui a amené davantage de militants
qui ont pris leur carte pour pouvoir
voter au congrès est qui a remis
finalement les idées et le parti des
républicains sur le devant de la scène
au moins pour un temps dans les idées je
vous trouve un petit peu optimiste mais
si on compare les vulcains à ce qu'est
la gauche aujourd'hui c'est sûr qu'on
pour la gauche part de très loin on peut
être optimiste pour la république en
disant qu'ils sont au moins douze ou
treize qui nous sommes le fabuleux mais
qui n'est rien en fait par rapport à ce
qu'ils étaient avant ce qu'il était il
ya dix ans et comme vous le dites y'a
aucun leader pour l'instant qui se
dégage donc on verra de l'appareil va
l'emporter est ce que vous qui m a
poussé michel barnier qui gagnera une
fille née puisque xavier bertrand
prendra le lead mais je trouve oui le
problème c'est de ces parties là c'est
qu'ils ont encore des troupes on a vu au
niveau local on l'a vu aux régionales ou
départementales les mots municipal mais
ils ont plein d'idées et ou alors leurs
idées sont soit celle de ce qu'on
appelle l'extrême droite soit celle d'
emmanuel macron donc ils sont pris au
piège des manuels macron inquiet que je
termine juste part dans tes que soit il
se radicalise et dans ce cas là ils sont
exclus du cercle de la raison soit ils
vont sur les positions plus mignonne à
croquer déjà et en isère garder ce sont
que de pâles copies du président qui est
déjà là mais c'est que sur cette impasse
idéologique
à droite c'est clair il ya deux camps
maintenant qu'ils sont claires le camp
quand nationale comme il s'auto appelle
lui-même avec zemmour marine le pen et
ces idées là et le camp a dit de la
raison comme j'avais encore il s'appelle
lui-même avec les centristes la maison
commune mails macron qui est le centre
droit classique donc on refait
finalement l'éclatement de la droite à
l'ancienne à gauche je crois que c'est
encore pire pour ce qui est de
l'idéologie puisque ils sont tous sur le
créneau social-démocrate sauf jean luc
mélenchon qui essaye d'être sur un
créneau plus de la gauche post marxiste
et là c'est pareil on a l'impression que
même le mot il ya logis est un gros mot
c'est à dire qu'il ne faut surtout pas
avoir de débat d'idées on est tous
d'accord et donc on crée un ennemi on le
fantasme on ne veut surtout pas savoir
ce qui se raconte et on perd finalement
le combat et on perd sur tous les
électeurs parce que derrière qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on va s'intéresser à la
politique c'est qu'on va se passionner
pour des idées on va se passionner aussi
pour une certaine vision du monde et là
je vois que c'est encore pire à gauche
qu'à droite parce qu'à droite certes
c'est dévié idée certes il y à une
impasse parce qu'il faut choisir son
camp mais au moins les choses sont plus
terre à gauche on a l'impression que
même le terme de débats idéologiques est
un gros mot alors encore une fois pas
d'accord avec vous je trouve ça plus
d'idées aujourd'hui à gauche qu'à droite
c'est à dire que j'en ai vous avez des
idées écologistes qui sont présentés
vers la gauche vous avez le problème du
pouvoir d'achat sociales qui sont aussi
présentés par la gauche mais il reste
que ça n'arrive pas à marquer l'opinion
en tout cas la marque est immédiatement
fall fois d'achat si ça peut marquer
mais la gauche n'a pas donné de
solutions là dessus et parler d'écologie
c'est à dire de fin du monde possible
c'est comme parler d'islamisation de
remplacement
havas l'extrême droite gauche et eric
zemmour gauche marine le pen ce sont des
fin du monde annoncée mais qui sont trop
lointaines pour qu'on puisse pour que le
peuple s'y attachent c'est une
impression et c'est plutôt la fin de
mois contre la fin du monde comme disait
l'autre est vrai ce sont des idées qui
où les gens se disent à ce traitement
elles sont excellentes mais yves auquel
il n'adhère pas immédiatement en disant
je veux d'abord ma fin de mois je veux
d'abord pouvoir rouler sans payer trop
cher je veux pouvoir consommer là c'est
plutôt ça qu'il fonctionne aujourd'hui
et c'est ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs avec
eux à fabien roussel du parti communiste
qui est là pour dire moi je veux être le
candidat du pouvoir d'achat je veux
revenir sur le les travailleurs la
valeur travail qui doit payer et c'est
parce que c'est vrai que derrière il ya
un peu une logique du livre de
l'apocalypse on doit être dans le camp
du bien donc lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique ça tout le
monde est d'accord moi ce qui m'étonne
le plus à gauche en particulier c'est de
voir que tout donne raison à un retour
de la lutte des classes l'inflation
galopante l'explosion de la fortune des
senti milliardaire et pourtant on a
l'impression que ce discours là qui
pourrait être un discours offensif en de
dire redistribution des richesses un
impôt juste derrière la protection des
travailleurs plutôt que de voir la casse
actuelle faite par emmanuel macron eh
bien on a l'impression que personne
n'ose rentrer dans la bataille avec des
mots assez forts pour le dire oui
peut-être parce que la lutte des classes
aussi aura fait 100 millions de morts
entre temps au 20e siècle il arrive pas
je veux dire à changer leurs logiciels
et mais françois hollande avait essayé
en 2012 en dix ans le financer mon agent
on a vu très peu d'effet je pense que
les les électeurs sont assez dégoûté des
réponses que donne la gauche à ses
soucis là et aujourd'hui quand on voit
que la gauche tout additionné fait moins
de 30% maintenant c'est à dire portant
de philippe poutou jusqu au parti
socialiste ça montre quand même une
désaffection des français
ce plan aux pompes au moins d'un point
de vue économique sans parler des
contradictions qui peut y avoir je vais
monsieur mélenchon par exemple il va
essayer de rassembler
l'islam au chili et du veau qui se veut
donc bon courage pour essayer de le
rassembler les deux et les actionnistes
ça y est les abstentionnistes en plus
soit là mais je pense pas vains pour
l'instant on voit mal la gauche se
rassembler sur une candidature commune
où au moins une voiture car vous l'aurez
plusieurs des programmes ça me paraît
compliqué effectivement en l'état actuel
des choses
place au débat de la semaine re devenue
l'épicentre de l'épidémie l'europe est
confrontée à une cinquième vague de
colère face à la montée des
contaminations les restrictions
sanitaires se multiplient couvre-feu aux
pays-bas confinement total en autriche
et partielle en slovaquie résultat la
tension monte entre manifestations et
heurts et les européens semblent refuser
le retour de la contrainte tout comme en
guadeloupe et en martinique où la
situation est très explosive avec une
semaine marquée par les barrages les
pillages et la grève les opposants au
pass and i ter et à l'obligation
vaccinale met l'exécutif sous pression
faut-il s'inquiéter de la reprise
épidémique pourquoi une telle opposition
aux restrictions sanitaires mais ouvrons
le débat avec une question messieurs
après les européennes et les municipales
selon vous à quoi pourrait ressembler
une présidentielle soko vide
[Musique]
il est évident que si tout le débat est
présentée pendant les quatre ou cinq
mois qui restent jusqu'au présidentielle
par le vide et par sa gestion
parfaitement ennuyeux et assez répétitif
ça fera deux ans au moment des élections
présidentielles on sera mort a été
confiné le virus sera apparu qu'on
aurait essayé plein de solutions les
opposants ont manifesté leur colère que
le gouvernement aura dix et nous la
raison et qu'on tournera en rond comme
ça mais c'est pour l'instant je pense
sans du tout lui prêter de cynisme là
dessus une excellente occasion pour
emmanuel macron de se poser comme le
pacificateur le centre de la raison est
celui qui a trouvé des solutions même si
c'est pas tout à fait vrai pendant que
les autres n'ont pas proposer de réelles
alors je pense qu'ils étaient venus de
la crau et a conscience que si cette
crise du coc vide perdure pendant les
présidentielles et qu'elle n'est pas
réglé son terme de mort en terme de
d'épidémie il n'aura aucune chance de
gagner parce que c'est ce qui a fait
perdre donald trump c'est ce qui fera
qu'il sera jugé peu importe le bilan sur
le pouvoir d'achat ce qu'il veut mettre
derrière les français jugeront sur son
bilan de la crise du coc vide et il le
sait et donc il va falloir aller très
vite d'où la troisième dose qui pourrait
éventuellement éviter de nouvelles
vagues d'où l'idée aussi de passer vite
à autre chose avant que la campagne
commence en janvier ça paraît difficile
puisque maintenant on a le passage terre
jusqu'en juillet au cas où les
françaises semblent s'habituer aux
vagues successives et les propositions
les alternatives même si de nouveaux
médicaments vont arriver d'ici la fin de
l'année sur le marché européen font que
on n'arrive pas à juguler cette épidémie
au niveau mondial c'est pas seulement
français mais pour emmanuel macron c'est
sûr que avec ce timing de la
présidentielle en avril il faut c'est
une course contre la montre s'il veut
avoir une chance de gagner c'est amusant
que vous lui prêtez cette intention ce
que tout lui prête l'intention justement
de surfer sur le sur le comité sur sa
gestion le plus longtemps possible pour
éviter de parler d'autres sujets pour
dire que c'est lui qui a la main qui est
le maître des horloges et que c'est lui
qui décide et il est souverain dans ses
décisions
quand ça concerne l'épidémie en disant
c'est lui qui est établie il passe
sanitaire c'est lui qui décide de la
troisième dose c'est lui qui va décider
du report du masque et j'ai l'impression
que ça me servirait plutôt que
l'épidémie
se poursuivent continue comme ça mais un
mode très bas parce que pour l'instant
il peut toujours dire regardez on a
mieux gérer l'épidémie que nos pays
voisins dans l'état actuel aujourd'hui
de ce que la france ait amené à gérer
que la grande-bretagne mieux que
l'allemagne aujourd'hui qui fait face à
une flambée épidémique mais évidemment
que les états unis mieux que la russie
et il peut essayer de rassurer les
français là dessus et je pense que son
bloc de 25 % on lui donne dans les
sondages aujourd'hui est aussi dû à ceux
ci il a réussi à rassurer même s'il a
menti même si c'est il a changé d'avis
pour l'instant personne d'autre n'a
réussi à prendre sa place le tuer il
aurait plutôt intérêt à ce que ça
continue comme ça on va aller l'écouter
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils disaient lundi
dernier à amir à propos de cette
épidémie
une situation qui est très explosif
qu'il y ait un contexte très local à des
tensions qu'on connaît qui sont
historiques et aussi à certains intérêts
qui cherchent un peu à utiliser ce
contexte et l'anxiété
expliquer expliquer expliquer convaincre
convaincre convaincre parce qu'on ne
joue pas avec la santé et on ne peut pas
utiliser la santé des françaises et des
français pour mener des combats
politiques alors on ne peut pas utiliser
la santé des françaises et des français
pour mener des combats politiques sauf
lui sauf louis voilà parce que lui
clairement on voit bien que il est avec
le sceau du secret défense un ses
conseils de défense à répétition il est
le maître des horloges il peut choisir
d'enfermer les hamsters dans la cage de
les faire sortir de leur donner trois
piqûres ou 4 de leur dire maintenant
vous avez un pass vous n'en avez plus il
a toute liberté je pense que c'est là un
des vrais problèmes démocratiques de
cette gestion sous le sceau du secret
défense de cette crise sanitaire il est
temps que le parlement reprennent le
pouvoir et qu'on lève ce secret défense
parce que il ya eu des scandales le
scandale par exemple du laboratoire eli
lilly avec le bam l'imam ce médicament
anticorps monoclonaux qui devait être un
miracle et qui s'y retrouvaient
dangereux 170 millions d'euros ont été
dépensés dans ce traitement inutile
c'est énorme et il y aura pas de compte
rendu sur cette erreur et y en a eu
beaucoup d'autres erreurs sur les masses
quand on se rappelle des nombreux
mensonges et des approximations
d'olivier ferrand c'est à dire que ce
gouvernement se cache systématiquement
derrière le fait de on ne savait pas
c'est le secret défense mais à chaque
fois par contre ils sont doctement sur
les plateaux pour vous dire de doses
vous n'aurez plus le virus de doses on
est sauvé on leur transmet pas le virus
quand on est vacciné et puis six mois
après alors nord de dos a suffi passé
trois doses et puis non finalement ça ne
suffira pas il faut aller plus loin donc
c'est certain brio navigue à vue mais
cet accord avec tivo allemagne au mois
de juillet 2020 avait dit il y aura pas
de vaccins y aura pas de politique
vaccinale sa mère ça ne lui rires alma
de passer du quotidien une autre fois
mais dont qui se sont un peu près
plantés sur tout mais comme personne
d'autre dans leurs concurrents dans
leurs opposants n'ont anticipé la chose
n'a eu un discours rationnel dont il
faudrait faire ça je pense qu'ils jouent
pour l'instant vraiment sur du velours
mais et joue sur du velours en tout cas
sur les plateaux de télé comme vous le
dis ouais et dans un petit cercle
parisien ce qui n'est a priori pas le
cas de ce que ressent la population et
notamment dans les îles commencé
aux antilles donc elle martinique et à
la guadeloupe et j'aimerais bien qu'on
entende d'ailleurs
cette colère qui s'exprime aujourd'hui à
la guadeloupe qui attend d'être réglé
je pense qu'on est arrivé à un point où
le pass vaccinale et l'obligation
l'obligation pour le passager terre
plutôt et l'obligation vaccinale a été
la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
vase en fait c'est à dire qu' il y avait
déjà un contexte social assez tendues
entre le chômage des jeunes excessif
entre les problèmes de santé entre le ch
le fait qu'on n'ait pas de chu le fait
qu'on ait raté empoisonné au chlordécone
le fait qu' on n'est pas le même on
n'est pas accès à l'eau qui est des
coupures des tours dont la cause que
l'on ne va pas au top je pense que oui
vous voyez je suis je veux même pas tout
énumérer les voiles ou qu'on a une
histoire dont apporte une touche
laliberté qui est fondamental pour un
être humain je pense que là pour le coup
il ya des difficultés à venir s'il ya
plus de choix comme je dis souvent si
vous êtes contraint et si vous êtes
contre un on est plus libre et si vous
n'êtes plus libre à vous êtes esclaves à
la guadeloupe sera t-elle la naissance
de nouveau gilet jaune pour emmanuel
macron c'est à voir on sait que la
guadeloupe est raide du scellement très
indiqué que la colère gronde souvent et
que donc ça peut rester circonscrit là
bas néanmoins je pense que c'est
vraiment un moment d' alerte et emmanuel
macron gouvernement devrait sentir
passer le le vent du boulet et
s'attendait quand même sur cette cette
révolte qui gronde là bas mais bien sûr
parce que c'est révolte elle peut
s'étendre au delà de la guadeloupe et de
la martinique est allé bien sûr toucher
la métropole en disant tout simplement
deux ans de gestion sanitaire
qui est une gestion autoritaire
liberticide ce que dit ce monsieur sur
le fait d'être esclave quand on le perd
sa liberté ça peut commencer à imprimer
en disant mais attendez c'est pas un
vaccin qui va me rendre ma liberté c'est
un pass sanitaires sur mon statut
sérologique qui doit me donner des
droits que d'autres n'auraient pas on
est là complètement dans une rupture du
pacte républicain liberté égalité
fraternité extrêmement grave on
enregistre ce matin on n'a pas encore
toutes les mesures qui vont sortir du
chapeau de conseil de défense d'hier
donc on attend comme tout le monde mais
on a quelques sources 1 qui nous disent
la troisième dose obligatoire à partir
de 18 ans sous cinq mois le finalement
le test pcr qui ne serait valable que 24
heures et plus 72 heures les
restaurateurs qui s'inquiètent est-ce
qu'on va revenir avec des jauges est-ce
qu'on va retrouver des couvre-feux des
choses comme ça on voit bien que cette
gestion
de de coercition ne peut pas durer sur
lathan le drame elle peut pas durer mais
où je suis d'accord avec vous sur le
stand terre vous le savez moi je trouve
que la liberté a été ordonnée par le
passé à lithaire le médecin non ta
manière paradoxale année normale été
confisqués non parce que ça aurait été
pire si on avait eu un recombinants et
comparons les chiffres des pays vacciner
a été siphonné pays - dax ine notamment
on peut prendre dans les départements
français d'outre-mer la guyane ces pays
là où le l'épidémie se répand beaucoup
plus et même en europe se regarder si
aujourd'hui l'autriche est obligé de
reconfirmer de mettre des mesures
extrêmement basses drastique c'est parce
que les gens sont beaucoup moins avec ce
n'est là bas leçon france autriche et
65% de la population majeure va ou de
plus de 12 ans sélectionnés en france
c'est 90% - l'allemagne c'est pareil
s'ils sont à 76 9 90 on voit que les
pays tous les pays latins d'ailleurs ils
sont l'italie l'espagne le portugal qui
sont au portugal ils sont vaccinés à 95
% peut-être mieux ça d'épidémie pour
l'instant et on peut pas dire que c'est
simplement le climat qui ont comme ça
vous voyez les cartes c'est vraiment ça
correspond mais vous et le nombre de
nombre d'hospitalisations nombre de cas
graves correspond exactement au taux de
vaccination mais malheureusement des dpi
taxi comme les pays bas par exemple qui
eux parlent de fermer les bars d'avoir
un couvre-feu à partir de 20 heures d'où
les émeutes qu'on a vu les
manifestations extrêmement violentes la
semaine dernière il ya quelque chose
fondamentale qui ne va pas dans cette
gestion dans d'enfermer de libérer de
dire que des mesures privatives de
liberté vous rendre la liberté on est en
plein orwell on a 95 souvent comme ça
j'en vois les toiles pour vous éduquer
pour vous de pouvoir penser tout ça me
colle c'est mal gouvernance et une
chance là le pas salutaire il n'y a rien
derrière à part de dire attention
maintenant qu'on sait que les vacciner
peuvent transmettre tout comme les non
vaccinés ou 1 1 certes mais ils peuvent
continuer de transmettre à quoi sert
encore se passer les nerfs il était là
pour que les français se vaccine
maintenant il est là pour que les
vaccins pour que les français pardon
prennent la troisième dose est-ce qu'il
va rester pour les 4e 5e 6e doses qu'est
ce qu'on va avoir maintenant impasse
élitaire avis la question il faut la
poser aujourd'hui parce que elle est
essentielle sur la suite de la société
qu'on va construire et je crois que moi
pourquoi je suis contre ce pas salutaire
parce que pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui va au delà de la stratégie sanitaire
et du vaccin c'est quelque chose qui va
au delà qui rentre finalement dans la
vie quotidienne et qui ne devrait jamais
rentré dans la vie quotidienne parce que
ça veut dire là vous êtes en fonction de
certains choix personnel en fonction de
la façon dont vous êtes
construits ou vous obéissez ou pas au
gouvernement vous avez droit à des
choses ou non or ce gouvernement il
gouverne sans contre-pouvoir sous le
sceau du secret défense c'est
inacceptable et les français n'acceptent
malheureusement ça sur le mode de
gouvernance suis d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que disait que ce sont des choix
personnel je suis moins avec vous on a
déjà eu ce débat pour moi hein c'est pas
un choix personnel de passeurs à
vacciner quand vous pouvez le répandre
faire du mal à des plus faibles des plus
âgés et que c'est pas un choix
uniquement personnel que le gouvernement
doit légiférer et commander selon le
bien commun tels qu'ils l'estiment
aujourd'hui bien commun commandes que
les gens soient le plus vaccinée
possible parce qu'on voit que ça fait
diminuer la contamination la
transmission que ça fait diminuer les
photographes s'étaient diminuer le
nombre de morts et il était il était
fondé à inciter les gens à aller se
faire vacciner si après on va se
retrouver à vendre avec une obligation
vaccinale un jour si les gens ne buvant
pas se faire vacciner donc c'est c'était
à mon avis un moindre mal on va là et un
entre-deux c'était bien il faut pas se
leurrer on va avoir un sas pour toujours
et une élongation vaccinale pour lever
le passe évidemment envie de regarder
vous avez des médecins de plateau qui
vous disent il va falloir vacciner les
enfants de 5 ans pour leur enlever de
masquer ce sera une énorme avancée des
enfants de 5 ans qui rappelons le ne
risque quasiment rien un de ce virus à
faire ce faire une immunité naturelle
c'est compliqué je ne dis pas que c'est
noir et blanc c'est extrêmement
compliqué de gérer cette épidémie mais
on est en train de rentrer dans des
tours de folie de d'otan dans une
logique clos c'est à dire que ce covin
réduit à la fois l'intelligence réduit
le champ politique c'est vrai il s'est
régalé ma grand puisqu'on ne parle plus
d'inflation ne parle plus de dettes
calamiteuse le sénat vient de retoquer
le budget quand même c'est quand même
historique et on continue à ne penser
qu'au qu'ovide comme si c'était l'alpha
et l'oméga le coc vide c'est certes un
virus dangereux est grave mais dont plus
de 99,9 pour cent l'humanité n'a pas
succombé depuis 2020 quand on regarde
les taux d'incidence plutôt que de
regarder les morts on regarde les cas on
regarde les gens qui sont porteurs de ce
virus pas forcément ceux qui finissent
est en réanimation et qui finalement en
meurent il ya une manipulation aussi sur
les chiffres la façon dont on a joué sur
les chiffres en fonction des taux
d'incidence pour dire vous avez le droit
finalement ce département peut enlever
le masque et puis ce département peut le
remettre il ya quelque chose qui enferme
les gens dans une logique dystopique
dans une logique dangereuse aussi de
peur permanente et qui mois
vu ce je crois que vous prêter trop
d'attention à ces gouvernements qui sont
d'ailleurs les mêmes réactions dans le
monde entier hors ça voudrait dire que
tous les gouvernements se seraient
entendus pour diriger les populations de
la même façon non des états américains
la floride et d'autres qui refusent les
façades mattel vient refusez vous voyez
que vous avez d'autres états comme la
russie ou le président ainsi que les
gens se reconnaissent qu'ils ne font pas
et qui se retrouvent dans des cas très
graves où ils vont être obligés de
refermer de limiter tous les
déplacements et vous avez un nombre de
morts colossal donc on ne peut pas dire
que là que le fait de vouloir avoir le
moins de morts possibles notamment en
vaccinant soit quelque chose qu'ils
soient destinés à contrôler les
populations à la fin moi aussi j'ai
envie de sortir de ce virus un jour
assure moi aussi j'en ai fait d'autres
choses et tout le monde envie de parler
d'autre chose donc plus vite on sera
vacciné le vite on sera sorti de ce
virus mieux on pourra parler d'autre
chose et moi j'ai pas envie encore une
fois qui emmanuel macron préempte le
débat jusqu'au mois d'avril sur cette
gestion la sq il aura tous les pouvoirs
là dedans et non vers le royaume savent
bien d'accord mais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut lutter sur le plan politique pour
le levée du secret défense et pour une
gestion collégiale de cette crise ce
qu'il est en train de faire puisqu'il se
rend compte qu'il perd un peu la main
finalement sur ce virus trop intelligent
mais par contre que le vaccin libère on
attend de voir puisque cette troisième
dose on se base sur des études sur
quinze jours finalement de booster
d'immunité ce sera peut-être la même
chose dans six mois c'est à dire qu'on
va se rendre compte que la troisième
dose six mois après et bien il faut
refaire une quatrième dose ce que dit
déjà ce que disent déjà certains
médecins en israël donc on est coincé
finalement dans un cycle perpétuel
permanent parce qu'il n'ya pas d'autre
alternative nous dit on
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous alexis selon vous
quels enfants méritent cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
alors cette semaine une info pour nous
sortir des phares du coc vide c'est la
création de la maison commune qui
arrivent ensemble citoyens avec agir
horizon le modem la république en marche
edouard philippe richard ferrand
françois bayrou jean castex qui vont
essayer de faire cette maison de la
colocation forcés pour être une nouvelle
plateforme de la candidature à la
réélection du modèle macron sachant que
on voit que l'idée de cette maison
commune c'est pas tant la présidentielle
le champion est incontestée c'est
emmanuel macron mais c'est plutôt la
distribution des sièges des futurs
députés de cette majorité majorité
complexe puisque françois bayrou avait
été le faiseur de roi c'est lui qui
avait permis à emmanuel macron d'aaland
et revoir cette assise voilà pour pas
longtemps puisqu'il était ministre
quelques mois avant que les affaires le
rattrape et là on voit très bien que
c'est edouard philippe avec la création
d'horizon en parallèle qui voudrait être
l'atout majeur des manuels mâcon dans
cette maison commune donc on sent que
les couteaux sont tirés que les
discussions vont aller très loin et que
finalement l'avenir des français est
très très loin par rapport à qui va se
présenter dans quelle circonscription et
qu'elle siège va être promis à quels
amis oui et peut-être qu'ils monnayent
macron devrait se méfier et edouard
philippe pour être à emmanuel macron ce
que chirac a été à giscard d'estaing en
son temps je parle d'un temps que les
moins de 40 ans ne peuvent pas connaître
mais le premier ministre qui serait
celui qui le mettrait un coup dans le
dos à la fin en essayant de récupérer de
créer une majorité qui est là qu on a
toujours pas réussi à voir 20 en tout
cas à ficeler file à lui en 2017 mais
sur des noms qu'on ne connaissait pas et
c'est difficile pour lui de rééditer je
pense le coup de 2010 est il va avoir
besoin de gens comme edouard philippe
dont la cote ne cesse de monter ce
qu'ils vont d'ailleurs assez
paradoxalement que les français aiment
beaucoup les énarques et quoi qu'ils
disent puisqu'il disait d'ordre emmanuel
macron et edouard philippe ça drôle moi
je voulais vous parler de quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec des énarques
ont pas très loin en tout cas qui se
passe plus vers la droite vers l'extrême
droite c'est
la remonte à da de marine le pen si je
peux dire sans
respect garde et arnaud montebourg qui
elle fait une vraie remonte à date
depuis quinze jours peut-être on la
donne est morte en octobre tué par le
nouvel arrivant eric zemmour dont les
plateaux de boris fait que vous rire de
son nom
qui arrivait avec un discours beaucoup
plus radicales qu'elles qui savait mieux
parler qui avait plus lui qui était plus
cultivé qui était plus intelligent et
marine le pen après son débat de 2007
était donné comme morte et ridiculisé et
selon le mot d'eric zemmour tout le
monde se disait qu'elle pourrait jamais
gagné même pas elle l'a ce qu'on voit
depuis depuis quinze jours c'est parce
qu'ils se manifestent depuis quinze
jours c'est que elle se faire une
campagne marine le pen c'est sa
troisième campagne présidentielle elle
sait aller parler au peuple elle sait
aller tâter le cul des vaches comme
dirait jacques chirac lc serrer des
mains elle sait sortir de paris et des
grandes métropoles là où il ya aussi un
électorat est avec toi qui as est
conséquent le caisson et lectures harel
ce qui fait qu'elle remonte à 20 %
quasiment aujourd'hui dans les sondages
elle sait gérer le temps long aussi
savoir un peu comment arriver les
moments stratégiques aussi d'une
campagne crois qu'elle bénéficie aussi
de l'explosion de la bulle zemmour qui
avait lui aussi l'idée de la nouveauté
c'était quelque chose qui a excité les
rédactions pendant quelques semaines
tout ça est fini il ya eu aussi le
passage à londres qui a été calamiteux
pour eric zemmour et là évidemment elle
ne préfère pas trop taper sur lui mais
au moins dit il ya quand même une base
certes je suis connue j'ai une histoire
j'ai des élus ça va beaucoup plus loin
qu'un aventurier de la politique comme
eric zemmour qui est d'abord écrivain
d'abord polémiste avant d'être politique
c'est sûr et c'est là où on voit le rôle
des partis encore une fois c'est le pen
quoi qu'on puisse reprocher à son parti
a qu'un parti avec des cadres qui savent
gérer une campagne qui savent
s'organiser localement alors qu'eric
zemmour est en train de créer ex nihilo
son parti donc on verra ce qui va se
passer en tout cas pour l'instant les
jeux ne sont pas du tout jouer et
l'extrême droite merci jacques merci
alexis au revoir
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]